first of all we'd be very interested
in getting the lithuanian perspective on
on the crisis on your borders large
border with belarussia kaliningrad as
well
and russian forces actually
in
carrying out exercises with bella
russian forces just give us your
perspective
well i think that what happens on biela
russian soil is a complete game changer
of the
security uh infrastructure or picture
that we used to see because there was an
amassing of russian troops at the
ukrainian border
last year spring last year there was a
military exercise called sapat
in autumn 2021 which we were quite
worried about
given that it happened at the same time
where we had experienced this hybrid
attack that lukashenko arranged at
european union border with a legal
migration
but
those finished and
we know more or less the schedule of
of new military exercise
that are about to be and where
and when
and this exercise that starts on 10th of
february is a new development completely
new
and we see how many uh russian troops
are being
transported to a northern uh
border of ukraine in the southern part
of belarus
and
they claim that this is a military
exercise that is about to end
by 20th of february but we know that the
numbers are not correct
and
then
why should we believe that anything else
is correct
and of course that worries us a lot the
developments in belarus are actually as
important as developments in other
places of the region in russia in
kaliningrad because this can end up with
a very high level of militarization of
belarusian
territory
could
these considerable military exercises
on ukraine's
northern border could they be
a pretext for an invasion
well there is a
significant number of troops at eastern
ukrainian border itself so this only
adds up to the picture and maybe
leaves us with uh thinking of more
scenarios than a couple of months ago
because it was quite a new development
and quite a sudden and quite speedy one
but
i cannot speculate i can only say that
this is a number of uh military uh
forces that were not seen in the region
i don't know since cold war
and in terms of overall strategy so many
people
asking you know what ultimately does
putin what ultimately does russia want
and it seems and i'll put this scenario
to you and see if you agree that the
putin is pulling back into his orbit the
the former
soviet states belarus already there
ukraine of course lithuania was once a
soviet state is it a case that if if
ukraine goes it's the baltic states next
we can call this uh
an attempt to
recreate something like soviet union 2.0
so i hate the episode of uh our history
that is former soviet republic because
our country was occupied by russia it
was never somehow you know never joined
voluntarily despite the fact that
kremlin tries to to
light other way round so actually um if
somebody asks me if i know what's
the kremlin up to
well i'm not sure whether the kremlin
knows it
but definitely what they are trying to
do is to have as many options
open as possible